a tank is a serious combat vehicle  capable of causing massive destruction  when seen in the game it should look  like the real thing  however we always try to strike a  balance between realism historical  accuracy and gameplay  there are numerous atmospheric elements  we would like to introduce this year  we are working on creating a so-called  volumetric fire the goal of introducing  new materials modeling is to show the  tanks is big heavy chunks of metal now  each individual track element is modeled  and animated separately we want to give  our players interesting historical  battles with as much variety as possible  we are now experimenting with modifying  the view range based on the weather  conditions on the map destruction of  structures using havoc a server-side  destruction model we even made a model  that breaks down into individual bricks  we want the players to have no technical  problems and the maximum amount of fun  Oh